place
[Applause]
try to remain calm there's a national
emergency haven't you heard yes that he
did it [ __ ] oh did it today he declared
a national emergency he was in the Rose
Garden in the morning it could tell this
is when he normally has executive time
because he was still in curlers and he
this was just completely crackers I know
I've said that before but this was just
one long baseless incoherent
stream-of-consciousness called the
nursing home rant I mean we don't you
know we don't even notice it anymore
when he gets stupider
it's like farting on a garbage ship who
notices
you know who should have declared a
national emergency long ago fact
checkers please there's there's no
reality anymore I mean reporters were
asking him questions at one point he
said to a reporter who gave him
statistics from his own administration
he said you really believe stats yes I
do I mean there is nothing really left
to say about this except a national
emergency should not be used by Trump it
should be used on Trump just to refresh
your memory why we're in this little bit
of a pickle we had a government shutdown
remember that over the wall and now
we're having a national emergency
declared over a wall because the master
negotiator was offered 25 billion for
his wall some time ago turned that down
in December he was offered 1.6 billion
turned that down now they signed a deal
for 1.3 billion today Mexico said [ __ ]
if it gets any lower maybe we will pay
for
[Music]
you know Trump promised his supporters
over a thousand miles a big beautiful
wall he got 55 miles of a fence and did
you see this they have changed the
slogan from build the wall to finish the
wall because he told them he said I've
already built the wall oh no he's built
no wall but he tells them that and they
changed this slogan you know Monday is
Presidents Day we've gone from I cannot
tell a lie to I cannot tell what I'm
lying just telling the people you've
done it I know we're not supposed to say
they're stupid but Ann Coulter is saying
that about them I mean I'm really at the
point now where we can just change
reality by changing the chant I mean
it's like if Queen sang we did rock you
oh yes we did we have already rocked you
I don't know
I mean it's madness
things haven't even gotten started and
he's already moved on to finishing and
Melania said welcome to my world
oh we laugh don't we but you know this
is fundamental really serious democracy
hanging by a thread kind of stuff it is
it's more of that slow moving coup that
I keep talking about the rules since
1787 in this country has been Congress
is the one who decides how we spend the
money okay
Trump found a line somewhere in
America's laws that said yes except if a
president declares a national emergency
and of course the only thing that
stopped all the other presidents are
moons before it is if they had some
respect for what our country is built on
but but one weapon that does not work on
this president is saying good people
wouldn't do that it's like using sarcasm
on Siri
but you know turning America into a
monarchy that's not something you can do
all by yourself
Mitch McConnell Mitch McConnell right
said you know first he was against this
then he said you know what if you want
to go completely around Congress mr.
president you have my support Wow I
thought Hannity was a submissive [ __ ]
I say we get an immigrant in there to do
Mitch McConnell's job because apparently
upholding the Constitution is a job
Americans just don't want to do
[Applause]
you